we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
quick listen to this voicemail hey David
I was just wondering do you think NASCAR
would be more interesting if all the
drivers were drunk I think that would
probably make it more interesting yeah I
think it's pretty a pretty boring or
anyway by you know I have had
conversations with people before where I
say NASCAR is boring like it's just it's
boring and I don't find anything
redeeming about it and people will say
to me David that's an attack on
Heartland values or they'll say David
you don't understand what goes into
these races where you are effectively
racing the car to its maximum capability
for hours hundreds and hundreds of miles
any small mistake in the precision
driving that's necessary could lead to
your death or the deaths of others or
potentially the loss of a race which you
were winning for the first 95% the
physical requirements for these drivers
it gets so hot in these cars and they
are doing it for hour after hour after I
just I find it mind-numbing ly boring
for whatever reason I do find IndyCar
and Formula One slightly less boring and
it's not because I have a preference for
European drivers than drivers from the
Rust Belt it's really not that I think
it's that I believe that Formula one an
IndyCar have more of the non oval
racetracks that I find generally more
interesting I don't know
I don't listen I'm not to use the quote
is this the hill I'm going to die on
it's not going to be defending IndyCar
in Formula One but even if the drivers
were drunk in NASCAR I wouldn't be any
more interested and I would be worried
that it sets a bad example that drinking
and driving is ok that's that's exactly
right yeah but I'd be interested to see
how the inebriation would be
standardized like we have a hundred and
fifty pound person do they have to drink
five beers and then a 200-pound person
has to drink eight it would have to be
done by a blood alcohol level right
which is sort of like the relative
impact of the alcohol in blood I think
is the way it would have to be but I
think we're going way deeper than we
need to because it's a terrible idea and
ask
would still be something that I would
have no interest in watching we have a
great bonus show for you today two ways
to get access to the bonus show first of
all become a member at WWE pakman.com
second option become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will speak to you on today's bonus show
in mere minutes